[Musique]
est-ce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république d'haïti
l'état de droit a été véritablement mise
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode de crapuleux on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leurs troupes et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire agnès buzyn qui était
ministre de la santé au début de la
pandémie de kobe 19 vient d'être mise en
examen par la cour de justice de la
république pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui une décision contre laquelle
fait bloc le gouvernement et la majorité
et ce n'est peut-être que le début des
milliers de plaintes ont été déposées
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire et
sont en cours d'instruction elle vise la
pénurie d'équipements de protection les
effets liés au port du masque ou les
effets secondaires des vaccins alors
faut-il juger agnès buzyn mais aussi
olivier ferrand jean castex edouard
philippe et tous les responsables de la
gestion de la crise hormis lé président
de la république contre qui aucune
action ne peut être engagée pour des
actes accomplis dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions même après la fin de son
mandat c'est l'article 67 de la
constitution qui le dit pour en débattre
car il y à débat évidemment esta débat
très très très intéressant vous allez
voir nous avons invité hervé léman êtes
avocat ancien juge d'instruction vous
êtes l'auteur du livre le procès fillon
aux éditions du serpent 2018 et dans un
entretien au figaro vox paru avant-hier
vous expliquer qu'en mettant en examen
agnès buzyn pour mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui
la cour de justice de la république pose
un sérieux problème de séparation des
pouvoirs alors on y reviendra sur ce
sujet mais vous êtes défavorable en
général et aux seins procède agnès buzyn
et de tous les responsables que j'ai pu
citer absolument je crois qu'il faut pas
confondre
responsabilité politique et la
sociabilité pénale il faut pas confondre
politiquement responsable et pénalement
coupable il ne faut pas confondre
responsables et coupables georgina
dufoix avaient utilisé cette expression
il ya quelques années et je crois que
les juges seraient bien inspirés de
s'occuper des délinquants et pas de la
responsabilité politique du gouvernement
bertrand mertz vous êtes également
avocat spécialisé notamment dans la
responsabilité médicale vous êtes
l'auteur du livre les réseaux sociaux
contre la démocratie palun peste de la
société du spectacle c'est paru chez
edilivre vous avez engagé en 2020 une
procédure devant la cour de justice de
la république contre agnès buzyn et
olivier vers en tant que ministre de la
santé une plainte visant le délit d'
abstention de combattre un sinistre vous
représentez en effet un habitant de la
moselle qui a été victime du coup vite
19 au tout début de la pandémie et qui
estiment avoir été pris en charge trop
tardivement il a failli mourir la cour
de justice de la république a jugé la
plainte recevable elle est actuellement
à l'instruction vous au contraire vous
êtes favorable donc à des procès pas
seulement pour les ministres de la santé
j'imagine pour tous les responsables de
la gestion de la crise
joue d'abord je dirais que cette
procédure elle est strictement
l'application du droit et de la loi et
donc l'invitation qui est fait aux
magistrats et notamment aux magistrats
de la commission d'instruction de la
cour de justice de la république d'aller
voir ailleurs je la trouve assez
surprenante je rappelle que la
commission d'instruction est présidée
par la présidente de la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation à des
plus hauts magistrats de france et je
n'imagine pas que ce magistrat engagé
les choses à la légère bon après il me
semble que dans notre pays
lorsque quelqu'un à se plaindre d'un
ministre il a la possibilité d'engager
une procédure monsieur
enfin mon client a décidé de le faire
c'est strictement son droit et je trouve
normal que une suite soit donnée à sa
plainte j'observe toutefois que seize
mille plaintes ont été déposées et que
seuls 9 ont connu une suite c'est dire
que sa plainte a été jugée sérieuse
alors le problème de la séparation des
pouvoirs que vous évoquez dans le figaro
vox hervé léman est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus parce que là
aussi c'est un problème intéressant et
soulève la cour de justice de la
république elle a été créée pour juger
les ministres qui commettent des
infractions dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions mais l'idée c'était de juger
les ministres pour qu'ils commettent des
infractions telles que des ministres
corrompus par exemple françois léotard a
été condamné à quelques temps pour
corruption dans le cadre de la sphère
des vedettes de taïwan ça c'est quelque
chose qui est normal si un ministre
commet une infraction de ce genre dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions il est
normal qu'ils en réponde pénalement en
revanche lorsqu'on est sur des choix
politiques c'est à dire lorsqu'on
définit une politique là on apprenne de
séparation des pouvoirs parce que
pour plusieurs raisons la première si
vous voulez c'est que en raison en
réalité cette politique c'est pas le
ministre qui les définissent les prisons
de la république le choix du masque le
choix du vaccin choix du confinement
c'est pas mal du zinc a pris des
décisions c'est le président de la
république on sait ça en conseil de
défense il prend ses décisions il lui
comme vous l'avez rappelé très justement
il jouait d'une immunité alors on va
rechercher la responsabilité pénale des
gens qui met en musique des décisions
prises par le président de la république
ça c'est le premier problème
le deuxième problème c'est que on est
sur une
des actes de politique et que les juges
ne sont ne sont pas là pour juger cela
elles sont là pour juger des infractions
alors on va tordre le droit pénal pour
essayer de trouver des infractions pour
aller rechercher en réalité des
comportements qui sont des comportements
de ministres dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions
réponse bertrand mertz
mais je rappelle par exemple que dans la
sphère du sang contaminé il s'agissait
pas de corruption il s'agissait aussi de
considérer que la manière dont le
ministre de la santé et le premier
ministre de l'époque la manière dont il
avait pris en charge cette épidémie
avait constitué à certains égards des
infractions pénales et c'est le droit de
chaque citoyen de demander à une
juridiction spécialisée par à l'époque
oui c'est la cour de justice cela public
existait déjà de demander à une
juridiction de vérifier si ces
infractions pénales sont bien constitués
pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils y renoncent
je trouve assez étrange à cette
invitation qui est fait aux magistrats
d'aller voir ailleurs je rappelle que la
loi des 16 24 août 1790 qui est la loi
qui sépare les ordres de juridictions
judiciaires et administratifs disposait
que tout privilège en matière de
juridiction et abolit tous les citoyens
sans distinction plaideront en la même
forme et devant les mêmes juges dans les
mêmes cas et donc c'est cette idée que
chacun a le droit de s'adresser un juge
pour lui demander
de dire le droit et c'est ce qu'ils font
mais pardonnez mac vous interrompre
bertrand m mais en l'occurrence le sang
contaminé je me souviens plus exactement
des dates mais c'était plusieurs années
après l affaire du sang contaminé et et
on a envoyé d'ores et déjà les
conséquences aujourd'hui on est encore
dans cette pandémie et on se dit que la
vérité d'aujourd'hui n'est pas celle
d'hier ça c'est certain et d'où la mener
la possibilité qu'on a de se plaindre
des agissements de tel ou tel ministre
mais ça n'est peut-être pas non plus la
vérité de demain et qu'au fond on ne
sait pas et on va et on va statuer des
juges vont statuer sur les ignorances
des politiques de l'est à l'époque mais
sur lequel les scientifiques étaient pas
non plus toujours à la bonne heure
dans la sphère en tous les cas dans
lesquels j'interviens les faits sont
clairs il s'agit pas d'une interrogation
sur le virus sur ses conséquences il
s'agit simplement d'un homme qui est
très gravement malade qui à 41 40 de
fièvre des vomissements de la diarrhée
et qui demande au samu centre 15 et aux
urgences de le prendre en charge et
pendant six jours on refuse on lui dit
on ne vous prend pas en charge à tel
point que finalement quand il est
hospitalisé il fait un coma pendant
quinze jours il est un tube et le
pronostic vital est engagé et donc j'ai
l'habitude de poser cette question
devant vos confrères depuis quand dans
notre pays refusant de prendre en charge
les gens qui sont malades qui appellent
au secours qui appelle à l'aide et qui
demandent des soins et dans la mesure
nous avons déposé une plainte contre le
samu centre 15 contre le chr et contre
la direction de la santé publique il
nous a semblé quand même qu'il serait
injuste de ne s'adresser qu'à ceux qui
sont à la base du système de santé sans
interroger ceux qui sont au sommet
puisqu'il semblerait tout de même que
les hôpitaux ont appliqué
scrupuleusement le guide préparatoire au
risque épidémique qui leur a été
adressée dès le 20 février 2020 et qu'il
recevait chaque jour dès mars
c'est-à-dire des messages d'alerté
rapide sanitaire qui leur disaient
comment faire et donc madame busin pour
le moment elle n'est pas condamnée elle
est mise en examen il faut croire que la
commission d'instruction a trouvé tout
de même des éléments graves et
concordants pour justifier cette mise en
examen je rappelle qu'il ya eu des
perquisitions et donc elle va pouvoir se
défendre mais dans le dossier il y a des
éléments d'ores et déjà dès maintenant
sans que l'on ait besoin d'avoir un
recul historique très important pour
considérer qu'il est anormal que les
choses se soient passées comme elles se
sont passées qu'en pensez vous evènement
tous les mois je comprends la position
de des personnes qui j'ai joué à mon
confrère là dessus et quand il dit les
gens ont le droit de déposer une plainte
bien sûr la loi déposée le 4 mai c'est
pas lui c'est pas la question personne
ne dit vous n'avez pas déposé de plainte
la question c'est est ce que parce qu'il
ya eu une prise en charge défectueuse
parce qu'il y aura eu en moi je ne
connais pas le dossier une particulier
mais je ne connais pas aller la
particularité des 16000 plainte déposée
devant la cour de justice de la
république et la masse d'ailleurs montre
le petit problème qu'il ya derrière
quand même le nom de plaignants on en
est à 16 milles mais y avoir reçu tous
les plaignants sur le vaccin ceux qui
vont se plaindre qu'on n'est pas assez
vacciner ceux qui vont se plaindre qu'on
est trop vacciner et ainsi de suite donc
la question n'est pas la démarche
individuelle des personnes qui portent
plainte et je comprends très bien que
quelqu'un qui a souffert il ya des gens
qui sont qui sont morts je comprends
très bien que tu puisse avoir une telle
démarche la question c'est est-ce que
c'est le rôle du juge c'est ça la
question est ce que c'est le rôle du
juge d'aller rechercher si en prenant
des décisions politiques dans la gestion
de d'une pandémie en l'occurrence mais
ça peut être de n'importe quoi d'autre
est ce que le politique guise se
trouverait ce qui n'est pas encore
établie est ce que le politique qui se
troue peur rey doit passer devant un
tribunal correctionnel comme un voyou
c'est ça
la question qui est posée c'est pas la
démarche individuelle des plaignants
c'est la responsabilité politique moi je
dirais en plus que quand même bien malin
celui qui peut dire ce qu'il fallait
faire moi c'est vrai que j'ai ricané
comme beaucoup de gens quand on a dit ce
qu'il fallait pas net de masques et
quand même c'était on était trop bête
pour savoir les mettre tout seul je
n'étais pas tellement pour le pour le
confinement mais je suppose sûrs que
j'avais six raisons que ça on ne sait
pas si on avait dit il ya une pénurie de
masques c'est très ennuyeux et ce qu'on
n'aurait pas eu des émeutes
ddd camions encore été
attaqués pour prendre les masques etc
c'est facile de dire c'est pas comme ça
qu'il fallait faire c'est comme ça qu'il
faut faire moi je crois que ce qui est
très important de ça et je ne suis pas
un défenseur du du gouvernement va pas
du tout d'abord ce pas des fois personne
en l'occurrence mais je suis pas j'ai
rien ne pourrait pas même busan et je
n'en pense rien de particulier mais ce
que je sais ce dont je suis convaincu
c'est que
toutes ces personnes du président de la
république
et son gouvernement ils ont dans cette
situation nouvelle dans cette situation
dramatique ils ont fait ce qu'ils
pensaient être le mieux pour qu'il y ait
le moins de morts possible voilà ils se
sont trompés peut-être j'en sais rien
nous ne savons pas l'histoire le dira un
jour mais ce que je ce que je pense
c'est que ce n'est pas au juge de dire
et le juge et les juges ne sont ne sont
pas capables de lire vous parliez de l'
affaire du sang contaminé toute cette
histoire de sont contaminés ça termine
et par quoi ça a terminé par une relaxe
de
de laurent fabius une relaxe le genre
génin du foie et une dispense de peine
pour edmond hervé tout ça pour ça mais
les propres politiques d'être en
politique côté poursuit tout ça tout ça
pour ça pourquoi parce que c'était la
même situation où on avait quelque chose
le centre contaminés on avait quelque
chose de nouveau quelque chose de
compliqué quelque chose qu'on ne
connaissait pas c'était c'était le le
vih qui apparaissait on ne savait pas
encore est-ce que ça se transmet par le
sang est ce que ça se transmettait bon
voilà vous vous souvenez toutes les
questions qu'on se posait à l'époque et
c'est facile de venir dire ah mais c'est
pas comme ça qu'il fallait faire il
fallait faire comme s'il fallait faire
comme ça moi je suis pour que passe
devant les tribunaux correctionnels et
devant la cour de justice de la
république les gens qui ont des
comportements malhonnêtes et injustes je
suis d'accord avec ça un ministre
corrompu il passe devant la cour de
justice de la république et je pense
même qu'elles devraient être plus
sévères que qu'elle ne l'est sur ces cas
là mais quand
les ministres essaient de faire de leur
mieux devant une situation où devant la
gestion d'une situation dans la gestion
de situations difficiles je pense qu'il
n'a pas osé au juge de dire c'est ça
qu'il faut
il qu'il faut faire est ce que on va
mettre en examen mus de la défense qui a
envoyé des jeunes soldats se faire tuer
en afghanistan
maintenant on voit bien que ça servait à
rien c'était une bêtise dans votre
délire d'envoyer ccc on ajoutera 265
jeunes français qui est sûrement en
afghanistan pourquoi pourquoi faire on
va mettre en examen les emmys la défense
qui ont pris c'est ces décisions qui
d'ailleurs n'ont fait qu'exécuter la
décision du président république nous
avons chaque année
des je crois 45 mille morts de la
cigarette est ce qu'on va mettre en
examen les métiers de la santé qui
n'interdisent pas la cigarette tout ça
tout ça n'a pas de sens on est en train
de confondre complètement la
responsabilité pénale la culpabilité un
comportement malhonnête qui méritent
d'être sanctionnés et des choix
politiques qui sont qui sont difficiles
franchement j'aurais pas aimé être à la
place de mon mb j'aimerais pas être à la
place de ceux de son successeur ni du
président de la république des ménages
général je pourrais pas te la république
mais quand il ya des choix de ce genre à
faire quand on dit on va au mali on va
pas au mali quand on dit on confie nous
on confine pas d'aller confinement et
des gens 10 ha mais le présent appel il
n'a pas volu confiné ça fait tant de
temps mort et puis à d'autres qui disent
mais le premier confinement ça a été du
chômage des jeunes qui sont suicidés
star à sa forme de choix qui sont
extrêmement difficiles ils se sont pas
les juges qui vont venir dire ensuite il
fallait faire comme ça il fallait faire
comme si bertrand mertz
il ne faut pas confondre la politique
publique telle qu'elle est définie par
le président de la république par le
gouvernement par le parlement et puis
des infractions pénales qui peuvent être
constitués à l'intérieur ou à l'occasion
de la mise en oeuvre de cette politique
publique moi je relève que la commission
d'instruction a retenu comme infraction
la mise en danger d'autrui - la plainte
que j'avais déposée elle ne retenait pas
ces sept motifs de poursuite elles
étaient fondées sur l'abstention de
prendre des mesures pour combattre un
sinistre mais la cour de justice de la
république la commission d'instruction a
retenu ce motif je rappelle que la mise
en danger d'autrui c'est le fait
d'exposer directement autrui à un risque
immédiat de mort de blessures de nature
a entraîné une mutilation etc faut
comprendre exposées dans le sens de
d'impliquer
de de mettre la personne en situation
bon
dans le cas de monsieur en bonis il
vient aux urgences où il appelle le
centre 15 est dit je suis gravement
malade j'ai beaucoup de fièvre venait me
chercher on refuse on met sa vie en
danger ce n'est pas une politique
d'ensemble qui est qui doit être
considérée c'est l'acte précis
la réponse négative qui lui a été
apportée quand il a demandé des secours
et donc je le répète au départ la
plainte elle vise le samu elle vise le
chr mais si les médecins si le système
de santé n'a fait qu'appliquer des
consignes qui ont été données par le
ministère il semble tout de même normal
de demander au ministre de rendre des
comptes moi je me souviens quand même
que madame busin elle a fait des
déclarations tout de même assez
étonnante elle a déclaré qu'elle savait
qu'elle était la gravité de la situation
elle savait qu'on allait dans le mur je
vois que c'était les propos qu'elle a
qu'elle a tenus et puis dans cette
affaire il ya quand même une chose
étrange dès le début on nous a dit on ne
peut pas soigner les gens ou alors quand
vraiment ils sont aux portes de la mort
on les hospitaliser on les met sous
oxygène
les un tube mais avant on peut rien
faire prenez du doliprane restez chez
vous et ses écrits ou ça comment est il
possible de re de dire à une personne
qui quand même gravement malade il ya
des signes extrêmement inquiétant qu'on
ne va pas la soigner et sa manifestement
ça a été un choix ministériels un choix
de santé publique qui a été opposé aux
françaises et aux français aux habitants
de notre pays et je peux vous dire que
depuis ma récente médiatisation je
reçois beaucoup de messages de gens qui
me disent mais mon père est mort à la
maison on appelait au secours on n'est
pas venu mais ma mère était gravement
malade on l'a emmenée aux urgences on
l'a refusé qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire il va quand même falloir que
les ministres nous explique pourquoi on
a refusé de prendre en charge les gens
et la réponse on peut la voir c'est
qu'il ya pas assez de lits dans les
hôpitaux et ça pose là également un
problème de choix qui ont été faits
depuis des années et là je suis d'accord
à madame buzet à monsieur véran ne sont
pas les seuls responsables
mais il se trouve que ce sont eux qui
étaient aux manettes au moment de la
crise et que donc il leur appartient de
répondre aux questions alors j'aurais pu
être moi j'ai rien contre monein busage
rien contre monsieur aberrant ont
finalement on leur donne l'occasion de
se défendre et de répondre aux questions
mais je pense que les français sont
attentifs à ce qui se passe ils ont
envie de savoir dans quelles conditions
tout ça s'est produit mais bertrand
mertz canton avant que la mise en danger
d'autrui
est ce que ça veut pas dire qu'il y
avait il y aurait eu une obligation
particulière de prudence ou de sécurité
et dans ces cas là quelle loi n'a pas
été respectée
oui alors c'est
l'argument qui est développée en dix ans
ils font un manquement à une obligation
de sécurité et c'est bon le le
texte parle du fait d'exposer
directement autrui à un risque immédiat
de mort ou de blessure de nature
entraîné une mutilation ou une infirmité
permanente dont dans le cas que je
défends la personne demande de l'aide
elle demande qu'on applique les règles
du code de la santé publique le code de
déontologie médicale et le code de
déontologie médicale il dit bien km ça
doit apporter secours à toute personne
qui le demande et qui et dont l'état de
santé le nécessite c'est écrit dans le
code de la santé publique et pourtant on
a refusé de prendre en charge des
malades et on l'a fait sur la base
d'instructions qui ont été données par
le ministère donc il faut comprendre
l'émoi de nos concitoyens et je trouve
et si je le dis
amicalement et confraternellement à mon
confrère cette idée que les puissants
ceux qui sont aux manettes les
gouvernants devraient bénéficier d'une
immunité d'une impunité par principe ou
une repas rendre de comptes est une idée
qui aujourd'hui ne passe plus il n'est
plus acceptée par nos concitoyens ils
estiment que ceux qui sont en
responsabilité si on considère qu'ils
ont commis une infraction pénale eh bien
ils doivent en répondre alors s'agissant
de de l' affaire du sang contaminé vous
avez rappelé quels ont été les décisions
de la formation de jugement de la cour
je suis la république je rappelle tout
de même qu'elle est composée de trois
magistrats mais surtout de douze
parlementaires et que donc lorsqu'on
nous parle actuellement de
judiciarisation de la vie politique moi
je vois plutôt une politisation de la
vie judiciaire s'agissant de la cour de
justice de la république puisque au
final la décision on le sait s'agissant
des deux ministres elle aura une très
forte connotation politique
avait les mains vous êtes un très fin je
reste parce que vous avez effectivement
cité la suite de l'article
223 du code pénal que mon confrère a
cité seulement à moitié et vous l'avez
vous l'avez compléter un il faut quand
même exposé directement à un risque
immédiat par la violation manifestement
délibérée d'une obligation particulière
de prudence ou de sécurité imposées par
la loi ou le règlement je peux vous dire
qu'avant je peux vous dire que avant que
madame busin soit condamné et valeo qui
va couler sous les ponts mais enfin je
suis mise en examen et là je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord avec mon confrère on
compatit c'est très bien c'est le permet
de répondre aux questions
ça ne suis pas d'accord avec ça parce
qu'on a un autre phénomène dans ce pays
c'est que quand vous êtes mis en examen
les gens pensent que vous êtes coupable
et souvent d'ailleurs ils savent pas que
vous avez été innocenté exactement mise
en examen malheureusement nous ne nous
le savons nous savons comme avocat qui à
chaque année je crois trois ou quatre
mille personnes en france qui sont mises
en examen qui sont ensuite innocentée
n'empêche que quand vous êtes mis en
examen et encore pas si longtemps cela
j'aurais se prononcent balladur vous
devriez démissionner dans le privé c'est
pareil quand que tu es tenir d'examen
vous éminence à un placard il en examen
ça veut pas dire vous avez à répondre à
des questions pour éclairer l'opinion
publique c'est pas ça que ça veut dire
c'est une démarche pénale qui est
extrêmement grave et extrêmement le
lourde de conséquence c'est pas
simplement va poser des questions pour
répondre à des questions il ya des
institutions pour sahin le gouvernement
il est contrôlé par le parlement le
parlement peut poser des questions le
parlement il ya eu d'ailleurs une
commission d enquête parlementaire
c'est là que les questions sont posées
et que les réponses peuvent être
apportées et puis ensuite qu'à la
sanction de l'électeur on est dans une
démocratie ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les gens élus ils sont
responsables de ce qu'ils font d'abord
devant leurs électeurs d'ailleurs madame
buses à la responsabilité politique elle
l'a pris en pleine face si je puis dire
c'est de dire que l était peut-être de
liste aux élections municipales à paris
elle a même pas été élus conseillers de
paris de de base donc c'est donc c'est
ça le le système c'est ça les
institutions la france c'est sa
séparation des pouvoirs vous avez un
exécutif qui est à présent république
quitte élus des ministres qui sont
responsables devant le parlement des
dessins des hommes et femmes politiques
qui sont responsables devant les
électeurs et puis vous avez à côté des
juges et des juges qui sont là pour
juger j'allais dire de tout sauf de
l'action du gouvernement parce que
justement on sait pas c'est pas ça et on
s'est suffisamment plein pendant
des siècles de ce que les juges
n'étaient pas indépendants et subissait
la pression du pouvoir politique pour ne
pas dire maintenant il faut faire l'
inverse c'est à dire qu'il faut que les
juges se mêle du pouvoir exécutif une
petit incident d'ailleurs parce que
cette affaire est intéressante à ce
point de vue là cette affaire et la
sphère du poumon en haïti
elle montre aux français que
contrairement à ce qu'ils croient et
continue à croire pour trouvant et
marées dans notre pays les juges sont
indépendants
si les juges n'étaient pas indépendants
est ce que vous pensez que il aurait pu
aller perquisitionné chez leur ministre
et le m
en izama allait ouvrir ses coffres forts
à la perceuse et le mettre en examen et
que le besoin la pesée maroc est un
phénomène qui est montrée en grande
clarté dans cette affaire qui est très
intéressant c'est que les juges sont
indépendants alors indépendant c'est pas
le début et la fin de tout on peut être
indépendant mais ne pas être impartial
on peut être indépendant et fait
commettre d'excès pouvoir ont peut-être
attendre et on abuse est exactement et
là je pense que nous en sommes nous
sommes à ce point là c'est à dire que
nous sommes à un moment où les juges
abusent de cette indépendance est bon se
mêler de ce qui ne les regarde pas
retrouvé vous permet d'éléments et avait
léman que ya aussi et c'est parfois ce
que les français ressentent ya créé
comme une impunité dans le cade agnès
buzyn vous l'avez dit est exfiltré du
gouvernement la mise
tête de liste aux municipales sachant
qu'elle n'avait aucune chance elle a
effectivement pas été élu mais en même
temps elle est devenue depuis l été
nommé halo ms l'organisation mondiale de
la santé et on a bien vu que certains
nombre de français pas tous mais y en a
certains qui étaient un peu scandalisé
un peu choqué zorba après après tout ça
très vite battant responsable de la wii
au niveau de responsabilité l oms c'est
quand même un peu agaçant il faut
retenir compte aussi je veux pas dire ça
ne justifie pas forcément une mise en
examen par la cour de justice de la
république mais il ya ce sentiment
d'impunité moi je comprends qu'on soit
conçoit gars ont soit agacé un je
comprends pas moi je comprend d'abord
surtout la souffrance des gens enfin on
a tous eu dans notre entourage moi j'en
ai aussi dans mon entourage proche des
gens qui sont qui sont morts du couvent
idées quelques fois dans des conditions
assez douloureuse pour pour l'entourage
donc je ne prends pas du tout de façon
légère toute la souffrance on a quand
même plus de cent mille morts
du coup vide rien qu'en france donc je
prends pas du tout ça à la légère et
c'est pour ça que je ne critique pas la
démarche des gens qui kiffent qui
veulent engager des procédures qu'ils
veulent mais c'est pas là n'est pas le
débat le débat on parle d'un débat
institutionnel et je crois qu'il ya un
phénomène aussi qui est très intéressant
que montre cette affaire c'est que
il ya une espèce de convictions il se
développe qui est que s'il ya une
victime il faut qu'ils aient un coupable
or il peut y avoir des victimes sans
coupable voilà quand il ya une épidémie
il ya cent mille morts il n'y a pas
forcément des coupables pour chacun de
ces cent mille morts voilà c'est un
syndrome ça nous est tombé dessus des
têtes des d'ailleurs il ya des tas de
drames qui est des tas de gens qui
meurent du cancer alors pour dire tiens
on va les mettre en examen les ministres
de la santé ont fait d'être là il faut
mettre il faut aller rechercher la
responsabilité des ministres précédents
qui ont diminué le nombre de lits à
l'hôpital vous voyez au niveau est ce
que ce sont les juges qui vont les
rechercher si on a bien fait il ya dix
ans de supprimer temps glee dentelle
hôpital et andy d'un tel hôpital est ce
que la responsabilité de sql ministre
perquisitionné et mis en examen parce
que il a supprimé temps le lie à eux
parce qu'il réduit anticipé le fait que
un jour il y aurait des des jeux
intelligents terme sur se répand très
vite j'entame sur ce point vous savez
qu'on est allé chercher des poux dans la
tête de roselyne bachelot y compris sur
le plan pénal c'est palais jusqu'à la
cour de justice de la république mais il
ya une enquête pénale qui avait commencé
parce qu'on lui a reproché d'avoir fait
trop de vaccins contre le le
la chaîne voilà exactement contrôle
contre la chine on le dit vous avez une
mauvaise gestion des deniers publics
dont vous allez rendre compte pénalement
parce que vous avez acheté trop de
vaccins voilà c'est c'est tellement
facile de dire après abbas a pas c'est
pas ça qu'il fallait faire je vous
interromps fait une pause on se retrouve
juste après et la parole sera à bertrand
mertz
[Musique]
cette dernière année a été plutôt
heureuse pour les bouches les bourses
mondiales alors que la crise sanitaire
on n'est pas tout à fait terminée
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
cette hausse vous avez le les banques
centrales qui déversent des liquidités
massivement et les flèches vers la
bourse aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
aucune corrélation entre l'activité
réelle le pib est le les marchés
financiers le jour où les banques
centrales ont décidé de tout arrêter
tous les marchés
reviendront à la réalité on risque
d'avoir justement un éclatement de la
bulle est aujourd'hui l'action des
banques centrales est bien plus pervers
que ça parce qu'elle détruit l'économie
rêve de nos jours il n'ya aucun trader
qui n'ose aller contrer le marché parce
que là cette force en question qui est
la force le des banques centrales est
trop forte
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on dit dans
les grandes entreprises multinationales
de saint gobain russie ukraine on a
beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et épaules vers moi je suis convaincu à
thé personnel qu il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc été observée il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays redevient sur partout partout
vous avez construit des vignes
décarbonés vos des usines où on est mais
rien du tout comme carbone dans l' usine
que ce soit nos émissions directes ou
alors des émissions liées à la
production d'électricité nous en avons
aujourd'hui dans dans le monde donc là
la conscience écologique aussi existe en
russie
[Musique]
il
reprend ce débat entre deux avocats
hervé léman et et bertrand mertz faut-il
faire un procès à agnès buzyn qui je le
rappelle a été mise en examen mais aussi
à tous ceux qui risquent d'être mises en
examen à leur tour puisqu'on l'a dit
près de seize mille plaintes ont été
déposées contre une vieille rencontre
jean castex qu'entre edouard philippe et
beaucoup d'autres évidemment la question
c'est patent ont-ils bien fait ou mal
fait parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
réfléchit depuis le début de cette crise
fans et sanitaires ont-ils bien fait de
confiner ont-ils bien fait de ne pas
confiné etc etc c'est pas tellement
ont-ils bien fait ou mal fait c'est
est-ce qu'ils ont commis une faute
pénalement répréhensibles parce qu'un
procès est un procès c'est pas des
médias c'est pas les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est pas je suis pour je
suis contre il faut démontrer qu'une
faute a été commise et qu'elle est
pénalement répréhensible bertrand mertz
oui mon confrère m'en a dit beaucoup de
choses je vais essayé d'argumenter point
par point d'abord sur l'article 223-1 je
n'ai pas oublié que cet article exige
pour que l'infraction soit constituée
une violation délibérée d'une obligation
particulière imposée par la loi ou par
un règlement et j'ai cité le code de la
santé publique et le code de déontologie
médicale manifestement il ya eu un
manquement s'agissant de la personne
dont j'assure la défense des intérêts il
ya eu un manquement aux obligations
prévues dans le code de la santé
publique dans le code de déontologie
médicale mais si je n'avais pas retenu
cet article lorsque j'ai préparé ma
plainte ce qu'ils m'avaient gêné s'était
directement parce que c'est vrai que
établir un lien direct entre ce qu'a
vécu
monsieur harmonie et la faute des
ministres je reconnais que pour ce qui
me concerne à l'époque je n'avais pas
considéré que j'étais en mesure
d'établir ce lien c'est pour ça que
j'étais resté sur la fraction du fait de
ne pas avoir pris les mesures de nature
à combattre 1,6 et c'est ce que je
relève c'est que entre temps la
commission d'instruction a procédé à des
perquisitions et
elle a probablement dû trouver des
éléments qui vont dans le sens d'une
éventuelle culpabilité
j'ajoute que la présidente de la
commission d'instruction m'avait
contacté en me demandant de caractériser
la faute des ministres et donc j'avais
approfondie est recherché c'est là que
j'avais indiqué à la commission
d'instruction que pendant tout
l'épidémie le ministère de la santé a
piloté journellement quotidiennement les
pratiques médicales la manière dont les
malades étaient appréhendés avec ses
fameux mars à ces ménages ces messages d
alerte rapide sanitaire en disant vous
faites comme ça vous faites comme ça
alors c'est peut-être ça qui a amené la
commission d'instruction à retenir la
fraction de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui moi ça n'est pas une infraction
que j'avais retenu mais en tout état de
cause je partage l'avis de mon confrère
quand il dit qu'il faut rechercher une
infraction pénale et donc il ne s'agit
pas pour la justice de juger la
politique d'ensemble la politique de
santé publique telle qu'elle a été
conduite à l'occasion de cette crise
sanitaire mais de vérifier si à
l'occasion de la conduite de cette
politique sanitaire une ou plusieurs
infractions pénales n'ont pas été
commises par les ministres bon alors
ensuite il pose la question de la
séparation des pouvoirs mais j'ai lu le
texte de mon confrère les mandants dans
le figaro rend très intéressant et j'ai
relevé qu il il appelle à l'aide si je
peux dire la théorie des actes de
gouvernement et dit le conseil d'état
qui peut annuler les axes du pouvoir
exécutif a développé la théorie des
actes de gouvernement qui interdit de
juger qui est de juger les juges si je
n'évoque est interdite ou juge plus
exactement de juger l'action du
gouvernement mais c'est une très vieille
théorie qui a été développé par le
conseil d'état au 19e siècle avec
l'arrêt jacques laffite d'abord un puits
la réduc d'aumale ensuite mais si je
puis dire le conseiller d'état a
lui-même régler son compte à cette
théorie dans l'arrêt prince napoléon en
1875 où il dit que finalement ça n'est
pas possible que ça reviendrait à
interdire ou jugé notamment au juge
administratif puisqu'on parle du conseil
d'état de juger l'action de
l'administration l'action de l'état et
le le conseil d'état depuis longtemps a
réduit cette cette jurisprudence sur les
actes du gouvernement uniquement aux
rapports entre les pouvoirs publics
c'est à dire les rapports
essentiellement entre le gouvernement et
le parlement et puis aux actions en
rapport avec les affaires étrangères
avec la guerre avec la défense voilà en
dehors de ça le juge administratif peut
juger les actes du gouvernement mais
c'est ça le principe de la séparation
des pouvoirs je rappelle le principe de
montesquieu c'est que par l'organisation
des choses le pouvoir doit arrêter le
pouvoir il se trouve que sous la vème
république la justice n'est pas un
pouvoir n est qu une simple autorité
c'est dire la méfiance que le général de
gaulle et les constituants de 58 avait à
l'égard de la justice me me semble que
ce qui constituerait un progrès de notre
état de droit et je l'avais écrit dans
une adresse au garde des sceaux nouveau
garde des sceaux il ya un an au mois de
juillet l'année dernière quand il est
devenu ministre ce qui constituerait un
véritable progrès de notre étrave de
l'état de droit ça serait de constituer
la justice comme un véritable pouvoir
juridictionnel qui rassemblerait la
justice judiciaire la justice
administrative la justice
constitutionnelle la cour des comptes
également pour véritablement constituer
un véritable pouvoir juridictionnel qui
équilibrerait les pouvoirs donc oui
c'est sans doute une différence que
j'avais contre mon confrère moins ça ne
me choque pas que la justice puisse
demander des comptes au ministre pour ce
qui concerne les actions qui l'ont
conduite dans l'exercice de leur mandat
ministériel
ça me paraît être la stricte application
du principe de la séparation des
pouvoirs tel qu'il a été pensé au xviiie
siècle par montesquieu pour aller dans
le sens de bertrand mertz on ne pourrait
dire même que cette ce pouvoir des juges
sur la politique c'est le sait l'état de
droit au fond sinon on pourrait faire
n'importe quoi aujourd'hui si attentes
politiques qui sont qui veulent remettre
en cause voire abolir l'état de droit et
ça revient quand même assez
régulièrement c'est justement parce
qu'ils ont l'impression que les justes
peuvent les empêcher de faire de la
politique et c'est vrai c'est le cas
alors il ya beaucoup à dire sur la
notion d'état de droit il faut s en va
exactement c'est l'instant où il ya une
où il ya un conseil constitutionnel où
il ya une cour européenne de justice et
des droits de l'homme oui on sait bien
que les politiques sont obligés de s'y
soumettre absolument mais vous avez
effectivement tout à tout un ensemble de
deux mécanismes d'alcon c'est
constitutionnel qui en effet va annuler
une loi qui serait contraire à la
constitution vous avez la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui va
pouvoir dire telle ou telle loi est
contraire à la convention perdre hommes
vous avez la cour des comptes qui va
venir contrôler la gestion financière
donc vous avez des des mécanismes de
contre-pouvoir par rapport à l'action du
gouvernement et que vous avez quand même
c'est son rôle en principe le parlement
qui contrôlent l'action du gouvernement
même si une petite dérive de godillots
qui est qui qui n'est pas très heureuse
mais enfin l'institution est le elle est
le prévoit et le gouvernement est
responsable devant le parlement c'est
d'accord en théorie la forme et
nationales pour renverser le
gouvernement si si l'assemblée nationale
le souhaite mais ça c'est une autre
question ça c'est le fonctionnement des
institutions mon confrère remonte à
dundo mal
très bien mais c'est le fonctionnement
des institutions pas de mode mais depuis
la république donc ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne comme ça la question
aujourd'hui c'est pas celle là la
question c'est est ce que quand tu as un
ministre dans l'exercice de sa fonction
ministérielle fait un choix politique en
l'occurrence de politique de santé mais
ça peut être de politique d'autres
choses encore une fois ça peut être vous
pouvez prendre des décisions jeudi le
ministre de la défense qui envoie des
soldats le ministre de l'intérieur qui
va faire des choix de deux de maintien
de l'ordre qui va dire bah tiens pour
tel type de maintien de l'ordre on va
utiliser tel type de l'instrument par
exemple on a parlé à un moment des
flashball voilà est-ce qu'il faut mettre
en examen le ministre l'intérieur qui a
doté les policiers de flashball parce
que des policiers en ont
abusé voilà c'est ça la question la
question c'est est-ce que ces choix
politiques doivent amener le juge pénal
a dit rabais ce lissage celui là je le
mets devant la cour de justice il va
être condamné pénalement parce que
l'idée quand même c'est pas seulement de
mettre en examen et puis de faire un bon
procès c'est que si on considère que un
ministre à comines
une faute pénale qui a entraîné la mort
de deux personnes la conséquence ce sera
normalement qu'il aille en prison mais
si on suit cette cette logique est ce
que c'est ça le le système nomade
d'abord d'abord dans quelle démocratie
ça existe ça mais regardons mais je me
souviens d'un article très important
dans le droit pénal en france c'est tout
fait quelconque de l'homme qui cause à
autrui un dommage doit être réparé et
pareil mais la réparation 82 voila voila
c'est la plage dix ans après on se dit
qu'après tout on a vu pendant toute
cette crise et pas seulement pensent et
disent mais là c'était particulièrement
notable on a vu quand même beaucoup
d'arrogance beaucoup d'ignorance aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de bureaucratie
bertrand merde si cette allusion
beaucoup d'autosatisfaction après les
faits aussi et on se dit quand même s'il
ya eu des dommages on comprend que les
gens se souviennent de cet article du
code pénal alors excusez-moi mais
certains disent ils il a
habité civile mais mais cet article est
ce qu'il dit des victimes doit être
réparé ça veut pas dire il faut mettre
les en prison les gens qui les gens qui
ont tireront que qui ont
géré un rapport avec avec ce ce
préjudice cc c'est ça la question la
question c'est
c'est aujourd'hui est ce que parce qu'il
ya une victime il y as forcément un
coupable
mais oui moi je poursuis sur la ligne de
mon confrère il prend l'exemple d'un
ministre de l'intérieur qui donnerait
l'ordre à ses fonctionnaires de police
ou de gendarmerie parce que la
gendarmerie est maintenant sous les
ordres du ministère de l'intérieur de
faire des des tirs tendus
avec toutes les conséquences que l'on
sait évidemment qu'il faudrait déposé
une plainte contre lui il poursuivre
pénalement pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils
bénéficient d'un privilège d'une
immunité si un ministre dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions donne un ordre qui est
manifestement illégal et qui entraîne
des conséquences préjudiciables et qui
par ailleurs est constitutive
d'infractions pénales pourquoi voulez
vous qu'ils soient préservés de
poursuites pénales on pourrait
l'imaginer on peut imaginer un ministre
qui donnerait des ordres un ministre de
l'intérieur qui donnerait des ordres
pour réprimer une manifestation qui
seraient des ordres manifestement
illégaux d'ailleurs chers confrères vous
rappeler que la théorie administrative a
développé le la théorie dite des manches
de lustre in réfléchi et des baïonnettes
et intelligente pour dire justement que
les fonctionnaires si on leur donne un
ordre manifestement illégal
ils doivent refuser de l'appliquer c'est
bien la preuve que il a été envisagé dès
le début que un ordre venant même du
ministre peut être contraire à la loi y
compris à la loi pénale donc moi
personnellement ça ne me choque pas je
ne vois pas pourquoi on veut donner à
tester des ministres d'une immunité et à
travers de ce pardon mais dans le cas de
la plainte que vous avez déposé je
comprends votre argument mais on sait
bien que ce qui est reproché à agnès
buzyn aussi c'est par exemple d'avoir
dit que les basques étaient pas
important et que rétrospectivement on a
dit ben si les masques sont importants
de nos produits ben alors ceux qui
n'avaient pas de masquer que rattraper
là mais elle dit c'est de sa faute or là
elle n'avait rien fait d'illégal
il ya des des décisions qui sont prises
en matière de maintien de l'ordre en
france qui ne sont pas illégales même si
par ailleurs elles peuvent causer à
autrui des dommages oui jusqu'à présent
pour ce qui concerne mme isson intérieur
à chaque fois qu'il ya eu un tir tendu
il n'a pas été démontré que l'ordre
avait été donné et il semblerait qu'à
chaque fois c'était un acte individuel
de l'agent des forces de police ou de
gendarmerie qui avait fait usage de son
arme mais si l'ordre venait d'euros on
pourrait imaginer des plaintes
s'agissant des masques c'est tout de
même assez c'est étonnant ce qui s'est
passé on nous a expliqué pendant un
moment un bon moment qu'il ne servait à
rien pour ensuite les rendre
obligatoires bon on peut imaginer que
des personnes qui ont été contaminées
dans un espace clos en l'absence de
masques se disent si on m'avait dit
porter un masque ou si tout le monde
avait porté un masque j'aurais peut-être
éviter d'être j'ai pu éviter d'être
contaminé bon mais moi je ne sais pas si
cela est retenue par la cour de justice
le républicain le paradoxe d'ailleurs
c'est qu'on n'a pas accès au dossier
quand on est plaignant devant cette
juridiction
mais j'imagine que après les
perquisitions qui ont été opérées si la
cour de justice de la république à
convoquer madame buses et si à la mise
en examen c'est que tout de même dans
aussi doit y avoir des éléments
importants parce que je n'imagine pas
que la présidente de la commission
d'instruction de la cour de justice de
la république
des magistrats la cour de cassation de
la chambre criminelle je n'imagine pas
qu'il travaillait à la légère qu'ils
agissent à la légère il doit s'il doit y
avoir des choses et je crois que nos
concitoyens regarde cela avec attention
parce que savent bien que lorsqu'ils
commettent une infraction
ils doivent en rendre compte devant les
tribunaux et donc je pense que c'est un
progrès de l'état de droit a progrès de
notre rapport au pouvoir à la démocratie
que d'admettre que des ministres
puissent avoir un rendre compte lorsque
on estime qu'ils ont commis une
infraction pénale et je le redis madame
but ça allait pas encore condamné
peut-être que tout cela se terminera par
un non lieu ou par une relaxe et je
trouve que les acteurs de la vie
publique devraient garder leur sang
froid par rapport à cette situation
devrait admettre que l'état de droit
fonctionne vous l'avez dit les juges ont
gagné une certaine indépendance ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas et donc on
devrait plutôt se féliciter de ce
progrès d'état de droit et
d'indépendance de la justice
mais ne craignez vous pas bertrand mertz
que nos gouvernants ne devienne d'obsédé
au fond par le risque de voir leur
responsabilité pénale engagée et que
demain à la première épidémie on nous
confie mme strictement chez nous
on prennent toutes les précautions et
imaginables qu'elle soit totalement
superflu comme par exemple de nous avoir
laissé pendant très très longtemps le
couvre feu le soir ça a quand même duré
plus de six mois l'obligation du masque
dans la rue alors que on savait
pertinemment qu'on ne se contaminent pas
à l'air libre et qu'on a pas besoin d'un
masque dans la rue tout le monde le
savait tous les scientifiques ne savait
non nous l'a quand même imposé alors à
la différence du début on avait des
masques donc autant les rendre
obligatoires
enfin en même temps c'était totalement
mais voilà c'est une manière de se
protéger au fond donc la prochaine fois
on va avoir droit à encore plus de
bureaucratie encore plus d'interdictions
tout ça pour se protéger d'une
éventuelle plainte contre l'a déposée
par un avocat telle que vous à la cour
de justice de la république mais vous
voyez fedict avis je pense que la
question que vous vous posez maintenant
elle va au fond du fond du problème
c'est la question de la vérité ce que
les français ont compris c'est que dans
cette affaire du début à l'autre les
gouvernants n'ont fait que mentir sur
les masques sur les tests et
probablement que dans l'avenir des
débats à venir sur la question de la
vaccination de masse je ne parle pas de
la vaccination du principe de la
vaccination la vaccination dans
l'histoire du monde est un grand progrès
pour la santé publique mais la question
de la vaccination de masse en période
épidémique s'agissant cette maladie à
mon avis cela posera des interrogations
dans l'avenir mais je ne veux pas
aborder cette question mais pour revenir
à votre question à savoir on va finir
par rendre les ministres les gouvernants
totalement inerte qui n'oseront plus
bouger de peur du risque pénal - jours
ils vont nous enfermer ils vont nous
aurait fermé non moi j'ai été maire
d'une ville moyenne et un maire n'a
aucune protection aucune s'il commet une
infraction pénale dans l'exercice de son
mandat il en rend compte devant le
tribunal correctionnel bon ça m'a jamais
empêché d'agir lorsqu'on prend une
responsabilité publique il faut faire
preuve de courage ou alors on fait autre
chose on ne demande pas à occuper une
responsabilité publique de mer ou de
ministre si on a peur et donc dire que
les ministres ont besoin d'une
protection juridique parce que sinon ils
auront peur ils ne feront plus rien
franchement je redis ce fait autre chose
ça n'est pas un argument recevable ce
n'est pas possible les français ne
pourraient pas le comprendre
mon confrère
vous voyez bien la perversion de la mise
en examen avec mon confrère dit quand
même six magistrats de la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation ont
mis en examen c'est quand même que le
dossier sérieux j'ai pas vu le dossier
dit mon confrère mais c'est qu'il vous
voyez la perversion d'un mise en examen
c'est c'est pas tous les sons feu 1 si
elle est mise en examen c'est qu'il ya
bien des choses à se reprocher et ça
vous colle ça vous colle pas ce que ça
va durer cinquante cette histoire moi
j'ai écrit un livre sur la lenteur de la
justice donc je pourrais on en parlait
aussi et mon confrère le savez aussi
bien que tous les avocats donc ça c'est
là c'est la perversion de ce système
pénal de de la mise en examen il ya une
deuxième chose d'intéressant que le seul
vaccin plus tard avec ça j'avais presque
l'impression que vous frappiez la main
pour les mains pour les prochaines plate
que vous pourriez déposer les vaccins on
va bien voir alors on va bien voir quoi
est ce que on va poursuivre le ministre
de la santé parce qu'il a encouragé les
vaccins ou est ce que on va poursuivre
le miz et la santé parce que il n'a pas
rendu les vaccins obligatoires pour tout
le monde et a trop de vaccins où il n'y
a pas assez de vaccins il ya des gens
qui vous disent le vaccin tu les anti
vaccins belize le vaccin tuent des gens
qui disaient vaccins sauvent et en qui
vous dit deux vaccins sauvent mais y tue
il faut pas taxer les moins de 12 ans
etc etc etc est ce que notre confrère
c'est une fois qu'on aura la réponse est
bien géré a déposé plainte contre ceux
qui se sont trompés c'est sale non mais
ça l'a pervers c'est ça la peur elle se
dit m et vous vous et vous vous dites
vous et vous vous dites j'ai un confrère
c'est une grande avancée de l'état de
droit moi je propose que nous avons
c'est le thannois je crois que c'est une
grande catastrophe et que oui bien sûr
c'est déjà le cas nous le savons les
gouvernants en place d'ores et déjà
s'inquiètent en disant est ce que si je
fais ça je vais pas avoir une procédure
nous avons déjà des ministres qui
prennent des décisions en même temps
qu'il regarde par la fenêtre s'il n'y a
pas des juges d'instruction qui viennent
dans leurs ministères pour
perquisitionner
comment ce que vous pouvez gouverner
comme ça et vous dites moi j'ai j'ai
administré une ville et j'avais j'avais
pas peur mais le texte que nous avons lu
tout à l'heure
il a justement été écrit comme ça c'est
à dire de manière très restrictif pour
protéger les mères justement parce
qu'avant que la rédaction de ce texte
les textes étaient trop large et les
maires se retrouvait dans le tri mal
correctionnelle à chaque fois qu'il ya
un accident dans une piscine ou dans une
dans une école et c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait ce texte pour protéger les
meilleurs alors effectivement la mère
maintenant ils n'ont plus peur parce
qu'ils sont présents un texte qui est
plus protecteur et on ne va chercher la
responsabilité pénale que s'il y a une
violation délibérée d'une règle et
entraînant immédiatement un risque de de
deux morts et cette
protection il faudrait pas la donner à
nos ministres je pense que c'est
déraisonnable je pense que alors je
rajouterais si je peux le dire que
franchement dans ce pays est ce que nous
jugeons pas d'autre chose à faire est ce
qu'on n'a pas des petits problèmes de
délinquance de ci de là est ce que on
pourrait par exemple demander à ses
juges qui ont temps d'aller se pencher
sur la politique de santé de mona de
buzeins d'aller s'occuper de ce qui se
passe à marseille où on s'est pas la
même juridiction bas ce sont des juges
et ce sont des juges
de paix la paix nos sondés juge
d'instruction ils peuvent aller ils
peuvent aller se tuer vous croyez pas
qu'on a un petit problème ça j'ai encore
un vous savez aussi bien que moi moi
j'ai des dossiers dans mon dans mon
cabinet qui sont chez des sujets sociaux
depuis 15 ans vous n'entendez ça fait
quinze ans que vous avez des victimes
qui attendent que justice leur soit
rendue et des accusés qui attendent
qu'on leur dise ils sont coupables ou
non et et les juges qu'est ce qu'ils
font ils ont perquisitionné les coffres
forts de leur ministre mais vous trouvez
que c'est un progrès de l'état de droit
mais pas moi je préfère parier un
élément on a eu quand même potosi bois
tous les soirs en france l'équivalent
d'un crash aérien tous les soirs pendant
six mois il ya eu 600 700 morts tous les
soirs oui aujourd'hui on est habitué ça
nous fait plus rien mais c'est quand
même invraisemblable oui c'est
vertigineux donc éventuellement c'est
quand même beaucoup plus de morts que
marseille on pourrait dire si quelqu'un
en était le responsable ce que c'est pas
en train de dire ce qui concerne les
buses mais si quelqu'un était un
responsable ça voudrait peut-être coup
d'envoyer quelques juges d'instruction
parce que vous allez marseille c'est
quoi c'est sûr et fait raison mais ce
qu'il y a quelqu'un dans ce gouvernement
et encore une fois je n'ai pas d'amitié
particulière pour ce gouvernement mais
ce qu'il y a quelqu'un dans ce dans ce
gouvernement qui à un moment donné c'est
dit je vais faire je vais faire un choix
en me disant ah ah je m'en fous s'il ya
des morts derrière ils ont essayé dans
une situation extrêmement difficile et
extrêmement nouvelles de naviguer pour
quand même il y avait pas si vous vous
souvenez il y avait un grand professeur
qui expliqué qu'ils qui suffisait de
donner je sais plus quel médicament pour
que pour que tout se passe bien alors
dit mais qui fera
voilà vous avez donné d'avoir refusé de
donner sous prétexe que c'était un
médicament dangereux en tout cas lui
disait il suffit de donner ça c'est pas
la peine de confiner c'est pas la peine
de ceux ci c'est pas la peine de ça il
suffit de donner ce qu'est ce qu'on va
le poursuivre les pour repose qu'il est
allé dire à la télévision parce que il
ya un autre poids aussi c'est que vous
dites alors on a entendu ou si vous
utilisez pour faire on a entendu
beaucoup de mensonges et il beaucoup de
tirs alors que le mensonge je sais que
quand je dis ça ça choque mais le
mensonge n'est pas un délit le faux
témoignage est un délit le mensonge
n'est pas un délit et nous savons tous
ce qui est des mensonges pieux quand
votre femme vous dit mattar au large et
une mauvaise tête ce matin vous dis pas
oui ça c'est vrai vous dites mais non ma
chérie tu toujours belle voilà qui est
il ya des mensonges que et il ya des
mensonges politiques et il y à des
mensonges politiques quelques fois où il
faut dire certaines choses parce que
sinon vous risquez d'avoir des réactions
que les crée la panique et la panique
d'accord mais là on est au fond du débat
voyez pas ce qu il nous reste
aujourd'hui malheureusement vrai au fond
du débat vous avez eu la gentillesse
tout à leurs frais d'ectasy d'évoquer le
petit bouquin que j'ai publié sur le sur
les réseaux sociaux et la question qui
est au centre de ma réflexion c'est bien
celle du mensonge et de la vérité et de
la démocratie évidemment que dans la vie
privée il nous arrive à tous demandent
de mentir si vous êtes invités chez des
amis si le dîner n'est pas bon vous
n'allez pas le dire ça c'est de la
politesse bon
dans la vie publique dans la vie
démocratique
à chaque fois qu'un décideur
publiquement et que son mensonge est
découvert c'est un petit peu de la
démocratie qui établit qui est abîmée
c'est un peu de la confiance que nos
concitoyens place dans nos institutions
qui retiraient est donc un petit
mensonge par petits mensonges on est en
train de tuer la démocratie et c'est
bien ça la question qui a été posée et
lorsque vous dites que les juges n'ont
qu'à s'occuper de ceux d'en bas les
délinquants mais qu'ils laissent
tranquilles ceux d'en haut les ministres
ce que comprennent nos concitoyens c'est
qu'il y allait privilégier les
importants qui ont le droit de commettre
des infractions et que surtout il ne
faut pas les inquiéter et que la justice
et les condamnations pénales c'est pour
les autres et c'est ça qui est en train
de tuer notre démocratie et c'est ça qui
fait qu'aux élections on a 25 ou 30% de
participation maintenant et donc
justement le fait qu'un ministre puisse
être amené à répondre d'une éventuelle
infraction pénale devant une juridiction
ces reçus par nos concitoyens par
quand même l'idée que bon quand même eux
aussi ils ont à répondre de l'infraction
est donc tout ce que j'entends parce que
j'ai bien entendu un sur les sur les
télévisions ou il est temps les
émissions auxquelles j'ai participé j'ai
entendu toutes les contradictions qui
m'ont été opposé à me dire mais comment
c'est scandaleux vous n'êtes pas autre
chose à faire etc mais et j'entends
ensuite lui constitué autour de moi qui
le 10 mai mais dans quel pays on fait
quoi mais pourquoi c'est choquant qu'un
ministre puisse avoir un répondre d'une
infraction pénale si on estime qu'il a
commis une rendez-vous courte quand même
de ce qui se passe dans notre pays la
question de la vérité et du mensonge
elle est essentielle ils ont menti les
français savent qu'ils ont menti rien
que pour ça il voudrait les traîner en
justice ça n'est pas possible vous
l'avez dit mais si le mensonge a
entraîné une infraction pénale alors au
moins qu'il en rende compte c'est ce que
a commencé à faire la cour de justice la
république et je pense que la plupart de
nos concitoyens en sont satisfaits nous
reste deux minutes c'est une affirmation
gratuite je ne suis pas certain du tout
que la plupart des concitoyens en soit
on sera plus moi je note au contraire
qu'il ya énormément de réactions 2 de
tous les bords politiques et y compris
beaucoup de confrères qui pourrait
pourtant on pourrait se réjouir vraiment
je pourrais dire génial plus être procès
peuvent y ait de gros seins
énormément de juristes de magistrats
d'avocats qui au contraire s'inquiète de
cette dérive moi je ne crois pas du tout
que ce soit un grand progrès de la
démocratie
je pense que c'est flatter le mauvais
côté du populisme qui est de dire à
quand il ya quand il se passe quelque
chose qui n'est pas bien on va aller
s'en prendre aux gens du château voilà
or c'est pas dégeu du château ce sont
des gens élus et si on n'est pas
d'accord avec ce qu'ils font et ben on
voit deux contre eux à la prochaine
élection
bertrand mertz juste un dernier mot
n'est pas le fait que emmanuel macron
lui jouit de d'une immunité
pour votre raisonnement c'est la limite
tu as peu embarrassant non ah oui ben
c'est l'application de la constitution
il ya bien longtemps j'avais publie un
autre petit essai où je proposais qu'on
supprime ces privilèges du président de
la république
mais bon voilà pendant l'exercice de son
mandat effectivement on imagine
difficilement que le président de la
république puisse être traînés devant
une juridiction mais à l'issue de son
mandat
pourquoi pas je pense vraiment qu'il
faut rompre avec cette conception
monarchique de nos institutions
républicaines et il faut appliquer la
théorie de la séparation des pouvoirs de
manière complète total telle qu'elle
avait été pensé par montesquieu et dans
cette séparation des pouvoirs et dans
cette répartition des pouvoirs la
justice ne doit pas jouer un rôle moins
important que les deux autres pouvoirs
le législatif et l'exécutif et je pense
que c'est un progrès de voir la justice
se renforcer et aller dans cette
direction
remercient tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis et je vous donne
rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]